all right so this is Joel Blackstock with the taproot therapy collective podcast and I'm here with Wynne Schepps who has been a therapist for how long 57 years 57 years and they're going to keep me until I learn to do it right and Wynne taught me Sunday school my son is also named after him and he was the first social worker and therapist that I encountered as a kid. And I stayed consistently interested in what he did until I became a therapist myself. And so Wynn is 86 this year and still working. Four days a week. You've got to learn to save so you can retire.
好的，我是Joel Blackstock，这是Taproot Therapy Collective播客，今天我邀请到了Wynne Schepps，他做治疗师有多久了？57年了。57年了，他们打算一直留着我，直到我学会怎么做好为止。Wynne还教过我主日学，我儿子也是以他的名字命名的，他是我小时候接触到的第一位社会工作者和治疗师。我一直对他所做的工作保持着浓厚的兴趣，直到我自己也成为了一名治疗师。Wynne今年86岁了，依然在工作。每周工作四天。你得学会存钱，这样才能退休。
Yes. I want to get Rich Lockett out and retire. Wynn loves it a lot. Yes. I want to get Rich Lockett out and retire. Wynn loves it a lot. Yes, I do. I love what I do. I don't have to work anymore. I just love working so damn much. I love what I do. So, Wynn has a children's book that we'll get to at the end that he wrote,
是的。我想让Rich Lockett离开，然后退休。Wynn非常热爱这份工作。是的。我想让Rich Lockett离开，然后退休。Wynn非常热爱这份工作。是的，我确实热爱。我热爱我的工作。我不需要再工作了，但我就是太热爱工作了。我热爱我所做的一切。所以，Wynn写了一本儿童读物，我们最后会提到它。
but I think, like a lot of therapists, there's kind of a lot of pain in his story, and his story has always been really compelling to me. So, if you want to, we can just kind of a lot of pain in his story and his story has always been really compelling to me so if you want to we can just kind of start at the beginning of your life and go through your career because you've seen a ton of history too
但我认为，像许多治疗师一样，他的故事里有很多痛苦，而他的故事一直让我非常着迷。所以，如果你愿意的话，我们可以从你人生的起点开始，回顾你的职业生涯，因为你也见证了大量的历史。
I mean like the profession you were trained psychoanalytically you're like doing therapy in the beginning psychoanalytically no I have a masters from NYU in psychiatric social work okay but you were in psychoanalysis and the supervisor I was in psychotherapy Analytically, no. I have a master's from NYU in psychiatric social work. Okay. But you were in psychoanalysis and the supervisor... I was in psychotherapy.
我是说，比如你受过精神分析训练的职业背景，你一开始是做精神分析治疗的吗？不，我拥有纽约大学精神病学社会工作的硕士学位。好的，但你当时在接受精神分析，而督导……我当时在接受心理治疗。分析性地，不。我拥有纽约大学精神病学社会工作的硕士学位。好的。但你当时在接受精神分析，而督导……我当时在接受心理治疗。
I've never been in psychoanalysis. Okay. But there was a lot more Freudian stuff in the water, you know, pre-1980. The cognitive revolution comes in and CBT becomes real big. But you've just seen a ton of history. You've seen the profession change. Yes, I have. So, I guess, where do you want to start?
我从未接受过精神分析。好的。但在1980年之前，弗洛伊德的东西确实影响更广。认知革命到来，CBT变得非常流行。但你确实见证了大量的历史。你见证了这个行业的变迁。是的，我见证了。那么，我想问，你想从哪里开始呢？
I mean, do you feel comfortable telling us a little bit about the early, the beginning of your life? Yeah, sure. I was born and raised in Ohio. I'm the second of two children. I have an older brother four or five years older than me. I pretty much
我是说，你愿意和我们聊聊你早年，也就是你人生的开端吗？当然可以。我在俄亥俄州出生长大。我是两个孩子中的第二个。我有一个比我大四五岁的哥哥。我几乎
always felt he was more okay than I was. Maybe a part of that comes from the theory that the first child is more like the more dominant parent, and the second child is more like the other parent. I was always more like my mother, and my older brother was more like dad. I didn't really know my dad because he was training to go overseas as a part of World War II. In fact, his plane crashed in Presquick, Scotland, when he was flying over to lead an armored infantry unit under General Patton shortly after D-Day. I was seven or eight years old.
一直觉得他比我更“正常”。也许部分原因源于这样一种理论：第一个孩子更像那个更强势的父母，而第二个孩子更像另一个父母。我一直更像我母亲，而我哥哥更像父亲。我不太了解我的父亲，因为他当时正在接受训练，准备作为二战的一部分前往海外。事实上，他在诺曼底登陆后不久，飞往英国准备领导一支装甲步兵部队（隶属巴顿将军麾下）时，飞机在苏格兰的普雷斯威克坠毁了。那时我才七八岁。
I remember faking crying when the telegram came that the dad had died because everyone else was crying. I didn't really know the man, so I thought in order to be a part of the family, I should probably cry too. The family moved to Hollywood because I had taken tap dancing for about four or five years, and I found out later in my therapy that I may have been living my mother's script
我记得当父亲去世的电报传来时，我假装哭泣，因为其他人都在哭。我并不真正认识那个人，所以我认为为了成为家庭的一份子，我也应该哭。后来全家搬到了好莱坞，因为我学了四五年的踢踏舞，后来我在治疗中发现，我可能一直在按照我母亲的剧本生活，
because she had been a frustrated actress. Please feel free to interrupt at any point in order to expand y'all. I'm proud to say that I even tried out for the part of the only white boy tap dancer in the movie Singing in the Rain.
因为她曾是一位失意的女演员。请随时打断我以进行补充。我很自豪地说，我甚至试镜过电影《雨中曲》里那个唯一的白人男孩踢踏舞者的角色。
But I wasn't cute enough or I didn't dance good enough. So that was about the point my mother developed breast cancer, which she testicized. In the early 40s, the only treatment for breast cancer was mustard gas. She received mustard gas treatment, but she died when I was 11. I remember being very critical of myself when I was standing outside of mom's room because I thought I needed to tell her goodbye
但我不够可爱，或者舞跳得不够好。就在那时，我母亲患上了乳腺癌，并发生了转移。在40年代早期，治疗乳腺癌的唯一方法是芥子气。她接受了芥子气治疗，但在我11岁时去世了。我记得当时站在妈妈房间外时，我对自己非常苛刻，因为我觉得我需要跟她道别，
but I couldn't and as a therapist I've learned I couldn't say goodbye because that would have confirmed she was dying and as an 11 year old I could not accept she was dying she died when I was 11 I began to stutter at that
但我做不到。作为一名治疗师，我后来明白我无法道别，因为那将证实她真的要死了，而作为一个11岁的孩子，我无法接受她即将离世的事实。她在我11岁时去世了。从那时起，我开始口吃，
point trying too hard to be perfect. I'm not sure why, except I do feel the stuttering is trying to avoid stuttering. And in my own talking therapy, I've had, I've probably had five or six different therapists. I probably had 500 to 1,000 hours of therapy
因为我太想表现得完美了。我不确定原因，但我确实觉得口吃是在试图避免口吃。在我自己的谈话治疗中，我大概找过五六个不同的治疗师。我可能接受了500到1000小时的治疗，
to get me to my present level of security. I moved in with my aunt and uncle. My brother stayed in Hollywood to finish high school. I was raised by another West Point graduate. My father was a West Point graduate. My brother moved into a different home when we were 11. And so I really, in essence, lost my entire nuclear family. I thought I should become perfect for fear my aunt and uncle might kick me out.
才达到了我现在的安全感水平。我搬去和姑姑姑父住。我哥哥留在好莱坞读完了高中。我是由另一位西点军校毕业生抚养长大的。我父亲是西点军校毕业生。我哥哥在我们11岁时搬到了另一个家庭。所以，本质上，我失去了整个核心家庭。我以为我应该变得完美，因为害怕姑姑姑父会把我赶走。
So when we went to my mother's funeral, my aunt told me not to cry. Your mom wouldn't want you to. Thus, the book, 80 years later. Yeah, you've told me long before the book existed, 20 years before the book existed, Wynne had always told me that one of his biggest goals in life was to write a children's book convincing children that it was okay to cry. So it's been a long time coming to write your book. Hell of a long time, yes.
所以当我们去参加母亲的葬礼时，姑姑告诉我不要哭。她说你妈妈不会希望你哭的。因此，就有了80年后的这本书。是的，早在书出版之前，甚至在书出版的20年前，Wynn就一直告诉我，他人生最大的目标之一就是写一本儿童读物，告诉孩子们哭泣是可以的。所以这本书酝酿了很久。确实是很久很久了，是的。
I was raised by my aunt and uncle. I was never ordered to go to West Point, but I was told since we didn't have any money, West Point is free. I could get a very fine education. West Point being the military army academy, if anyone's understood. The United States Military Academy at West Point, New York. But West Point's army, right? Yes. What's the Navy in Annapolis?
我是由姑姑姑父抚养长大的。我从未被强迫去西点军校，但我被告知因为我们没钱，西点军校是免费的。我可以接受非常好的教育。西点军校就是陆军军官学校，如果有人不了解的话。美国纽约州西点军校。但西点军校是陆军，对吧？是的。那海军是安纳波利斯吗？
The Navy is Annapolis. And then what's the, is it the Air Force Academy? The Air Force is in Colorado Springs, Colorado. It's the Air Force Academy. Why Army as opposed to another branch? Because my father, uncle, and brother had all gone to West Point. Okay. And I was living my family script, S-C-R-I-P-T.
海军是安纳波利斯。那空军呢，是空军学院吗？空军在科罗拉多州的科罗拉多斯普林斯。那是空军学院。为什么选择陆军而不是其他军种？因为我父亲、叔叔和哥哥都去过西点军校。好的。我当时是在按照家庭剧本生活，S-C-R-I-P-T。
My family script. I didn't cry. I didn't get angry. I did have the courage many years later to tell my uncle that when I was angry, I bore holes in his floor. Because my talking therapy that I did helped me know it's okay to feel what you feel. In fact, one of the theories that I've held to, Joel, is that if you're not psychotic or have a brain tumor, you can't feel anything wrong. So therapy has really helped me and being a therapist I feel a lot of people I know, if not most therapists, are people who have had
我的家庭剧本。我不哭。我不生气。多年后，我有勇气告诉叔叔，当我生气时，我在他的地板上钻了洞。因为我所做的谈话治疗帮助我明白，感受你的感受是可以的。事实上，我一直坚持的一个理论是，Joel，如果你没有精神病或脑肿瘤，你不可能有任何错误的感受。所以治疗真的帮助了我，而且作为一名治疗师，我觉得我认识的很多人，如果不是大多数治疗师的话，都是接受过
therapy and people who are trying to be helpful to others as a way of being helpful to themselves. So having a lot of pressure to go to West Point, a free education, in fact you get paid for going to the Academy. I go to West Point, a free education. In fact, you get paid for going to the academy. I went to West Point. I graduated in 1959. I did infantry airborne school because my brother, who was a West Pointer also, told me that I should.
治疗的人，他们试图帮助他人，以此作为帮助自己的一种方式。所以，在去西点军校的巨大压力下，加上免费教育，事实上你去军校还有工资拿。我去西点军校，接受免费教育。事实上，你去军校还有工资拿。我去了西点军校。我于1959年毕业。我参加了步兵空降学校，因为我哥哥，他也是西点军校毕业生，告诉我我应该去。
Should is a word that I believe comes from the critical parent ego state, not the nurturing parent ego state, by the way, for the record. So, I served my three years. I called my uncle, Colonel McGee, who was in charge of the military part of President Roosevelt's funeral, and told him I was going to resign my commission
“应该”这个词，顺便说一下，我认为它来自批判性父母自我状态，而不是滋养性父母自我状态。所以，我服役了三年。我打电话给我的叔叔，麦基上校（他负责罗斯福总统葬礼的军事部分），告诉他我要辞去军职，
and go into psychiatric social work. My uncle's words, quote, You'll be poor. You'll be poor, Winnie. All you got to do is serve 13 more years. And I had found the courage in my own therapy to say, Judson, this feels like it's terribly important for me to do, to help others and in the process help myself.
去从事精神病学社会工作。我叔叔的话，引用一下：“你会变穷的。你会变穷的，Winnie。你只需要再服役13年就行了。”我在自己的治疗中找到了勇气说：“Judson，这对我来说感觉非常重要，去帮助他人，并在过程中帮助我自己。”
But Winnie, you'll be poor. So I called my older brother, who at a certain point the audience may remember, and he said, go for it. I could cry saying that. And if my first book does well, I'm going to write another book called Go For It, and dedicate it to my older brother.
“但Winnie，你会变穷的。”所以我打电话给我哥哥，观众可能还记得他，他说：“去做吧。”说到这我都要哭了。如果我的第一本书卖得好，我打算写第二本书叫《去做吧》，并把它献给我的哥哥。
So I did go for it. I got out of the military. I called Adelphi and said, I'm ready to enter graduate school. And they said, it don't work that way, Sheps. You have to give us a transcript, et cetera, et cetera. So I got a job at a residential treatment center for emotionally disturbed Jewish children and began to learn about the field of being a therapist and as a way of getting to know my father's faith because he had been Jewish.
所以我真的去做了。我退伍了。我打电话给阿德尔菲大学说，我准备读研究生了。他们说，事情不是那样运作的，Sheps。你得给我们成绩单，等等等等。所以我找了一份工作，在一家针对情绪障碍犹太儿童的寄宿治疗中心，开始学习如何成为一名治疗师，这也是为了了解我父亲的信仰，因为他曾是犹太人。
I did enter NYU even though Columbia turned me down because my grades at West Point were just terrible. And I took a test to prove I was not an idiot. I got into NYU. I got a master's in psychiatric social work in 1965 during which time I had been coming to Birmingham to visit an Army friend of mine, and he had introduced me to a lady named Michael Kay. And that part of my life became history, because I did come back to Birmingham to work for the Department of Psychiatry, and we dated some more and I found the belief in my own therapy first psychiatrist, first counselor I saw that I was lovable as I was
我确实进入了纽约大学，尽管哥伦比亚大学拒绝了我，因为我在西点军校的成绩太差了。我参加了一项测试来证明我不是白痴。我进入了纽约大学。我在1965年获得了精神病学社会工作硕士学位，在此期间，我一直来伯明翰探望我的一位陆军朋友，他把我介绍给了一位叫Michael Kay的女士。我人生的那一部分就成了历史，因为我确实回到了伯明翰，在精神病学系工作，我们又约会了几次，我从我第一次见的心理医生、咨询师那里找到了信念，那就是我本身就是可爱的，
to include all my feelings if you're not psychotic or don't have a brain tumor you can't feel anything wrong so we had a wonderful 47 year marriage she developed cancer of the ovaries shortly after we got married and almost died but she got cured so we have adopted children and other than those rare times I could have killed them
包括我所有的感受。如果你没有精神病或脑肿瘤，你不可能有任何错误的感受。所以我们拥有了47年美满的婚姻。我们结婚后不久她就患上了卵巢癌，差点去世，但她治愈了。所以我们领养了孩子，除了那些我差点想杀了他们的罕见时刻，
and no jury in the world would have put me in jail I wouldn't change a thing Warren Scott are the loves of my life since I lost my life about 10 years ago to, unfortunately, cancer. So, I developed a practice in psychotherapy. I've seen, as I said earlier, 5 to 10 different therapists who have helped me know that I am okay, my feelings are okay. And I started writing a book in my head. Is it okay to cry because of my aunt
世界上没有任何陪审团会把我关进监狱。我什么都不会改变。Warren和Scott是我生命中的挚爱，自从大约10年前我失去了我的爱人，不幸的是，是因为癌症。所以，我发展了心理治疗的业务。正如我之前所说，我见过5到10位不同的治疗师，他们帮助我认识到我是好的，我的感受也是好的。我开始在脑海里写一本书。书名是《哭泣可以吗？》，因为我的姑姑，
because of my aunt telling me my mom wouldn't want me to cry at the funeral. So I began writing a book in my head and I re-met a very dear friend that I had met the summer that I met my wife while we were still dating, who basically told me I didn't have any guts if I didn't publish this book. And it sounded wonderful for her. And I thought about what she said, and I thought, that's right, and the book might really help a lot of people because family scripts tend to teach boys don't get sad and girls don't cry. That's ridiculous. If you're not a psychotic or don't have a brain tumor, you can't feel anything
因为我姑姑在葬礼上告诉我妈妈不会希望我哭。所以我开始在脑海里写书，我重遇了一位非常亲密的朋友，那是我遇见我妻子的那个夏天认识的，当时我们还在约会。她基本上告诉我，如果我不出版这本书，我就没有胆量。这对她来说听起来很棒。我思考了她的话，我想，那是对的，这本书可能真的会帮助很多人，因为家庭剧本往往教导男孩不要悲伤，女孩不要哭泣。这太荒谬了。如果你没有精神病或脑肿瘤，你不可能有任何
wrong. And in my own personal therapy with other therapists and my own practice as a psychotherapist, I learned that's a good thinking that I could share with the world in a book. So the book became Is It Okay to Cry? Dedicated to my friend, Pugs Douglas. I couldn't find a publisher who wanted to publish it. So I paid to have it published. And I'm very proud to say that I do feel that that dream of mine has been
错误的感受。在我自己与其他治疗师的个人治疗中，以及我作为心理治疗师的实践中，我学到了这是一个可以与世界分享的好想法。所以这本书变成了《哭泣可以吗？》，献给我的朋友Pugs Douglas。我找不到愿意出版它的出版商。所以我自费出版了它。我很自豪地说，我确实觉得我的那个梦想已经
fulfilled so you've been in therapy a long time the styles of therapy you're in are they similar do you notice like a change in things over time you know having been a patient and a provider you know for how many
实现了。所以你接受治疗很长时间了，你经历的治疗风格相似吗？你是否注意到随着时间的推移，事情发生了变化？你知道，作为一名患者和提供者，你知道，多少
years? 57 years. Yes, I've learned there are other styles, but the other styles are not right for me. Or I'm an old farger who doesn't want to change. I'm not sure, Joel. So you were a cognitive behavioral therapist, mostly? I do some CBT. I do some gestalt work.
年了？57年了。是的，我学到了还有其他风格，但其他风格不适合我。或者我是一个不想改变的老顽固。我不确定，Joel。所以你主要是认知行为治疗师？我做一些CBT。我做一些格式塔疗法。
I do some CBT. I do some gestalt work. I do some psychodrama. I like role play. But I mainly like talking because my talking therapy has helped me learn that when I lost everybody, I became what anyone else wanted me to be. I lost me. And in the last 20, 25 years, I have reclaimed me. And that feels absolutely wonderful. So I've continued doing talking work. I don't do EMDR. I don't do brain spotting.
我做一些CBT。我做一些格式塔疗法。我做一些心理剧。我喜欢角色扮演。但我主要喜欢谈话，因为我的谈话治疗帮助我了解到，当我失去所有人时，我变成了别人想要我成为的样子。我失去了自我。在过去的20、25年里，我找回了自我。那感觉真是太棒了。所以我继续做谈话工作。我不做EMDR。我不做脑点定位疗法。
You obviously do that wonderfully. But those things are not right for me to do as an untrained person. Sure. Yeah. And when there's also like, it seems like there's always been a three line of like a lot of the humanitarian, like Virginia Satir type stuff
你显然做得非常出色。但作为一名未经训练的人，做那些事情对我来说不合适。当然。是的。而且Wynn，似乎一直有一条主线，比如很多像Virginia Satir那样的人道主义的东西，
and what you've described your conceptualizations. Did you know Satir or go train with her? I once entertained her, as a matter of fact, in my home. Oh, really? I did not know that. Lovely, lovely lady. I do a lot of grief work because I've had a lot of grief in my own life and I do cry with clients when I feel like crying. She was a wonderful lady. She did wonderful wonderful grief work. She did wonderful book work. Rest her soul. So you're getting integrated then. I mean, there's a lot.
以及你所描述的概念化。你认识Satir或者跟她一起训练过吗？事实上，我曾经在家里招待过她。哦，真的吗？我不知道。非常可爱的一位女士。我做了很多悲伤辅导，因为我自己的生活中经历了很多悲伤，当我想哭的时候，我会和客户一起哭。她是一位了不起的女士。她做了非常棒的悲伤辅导。她做了非常棒的书籍工作。愿她安息。所以你正在进行整合。我是说，有很多。
I know about the way that you talk about cases because I've heard about it since Sunday school. You'd even bring cases in when I was in sixth grade sometimes. Without mentioning names. Without mentioning names, of course, yeah. No identifiable information. So I have a sense of how you think. I'm just curious how you got there, what you're putting together. And that makes sense that there's some gestalt and CBT and the kind of humanism, human potential, Virginia Satir stuff.
我知道你谈论案例的方式，因为我从主日学开始就听说了。甚至在我上六年级的时候，你有时也会带案例进来。当然没有提名字。当然没有提名字，是的。没有可识别的信息。所以我对你的思考方式有了一定的了解。我只是好奇你是怎么走到这一步的，你是如何把这些整合在一起的。这很有道理，有一些格式塔和CBT，还有那种人本主义、人类潜能、Virginia Satir的东西。
But it does seem like there is some more psychoanalytic concepts come up when you're talking and with most providers that I talk to. I mean, is that just more in the water in the 60s? Do you think everybody got a little bit of that? More in the water. Yeah. I learned at NYU humans are the only animal that spent 18 years at home the 60s you think everybody got a little bit of that more in the water yeah i learned that nyu humans are the only animal that spent 18 years at home and the next 40 getting over it
但看起来确实有一些精神分析的概念在你谈话时出现，而且我交谈过的大多数提供者也是如此。我是说，那只是60年代更普遍的现象吗？你认为每个人都从中得到了一点吗？更普遍。是的。我在纽约大学学到，人类是唯一一种在家待了18年，60年代你认为每个人都从中得到了一点吗？更普遍。是的。我在纽约大学学到，人类是唯一一种在家待了18年，
men tend to live through their male children men men tend to have the highest expectation for their for their oldest son and i'm very pleased to say that i and my son are doing so much better even kissing when um i learned to lower my expectations for him i'm okay because i'm okay not because i have a perfect son you know i think that is one of the biggest things that gets the unlived life of the parent out of the way is if you can just not make your kids be an extension of your ego and just let them be who they are supposed to be because who they are supposed to be is pretty cool
接下来的40年都在努力克服它的动物。男人往往通过他们的男性后代生活，男人往往对他们的大儿子有最高的期望，我很高兴地说，我和我儿子现在相处得好多了，甚至会亲吻。当我学会降低对他的期望时，我很好，因为我本身就很好，而不是因为我有一个完美的儿子。你知道，我认为这是摆脱父母未竟人生最重要的事情之一，如果你能不让你的孩子成为你自我的延伸，只是让他们成为他们本该成为的人，因为他们本该成为的样子其实很酷。
one of the other things I learned and you may remember seeing this in Walmart people don't remember what you did for them people remember how you made them feel and I've always been more sensitive than my older brother because he was more like dad and I was more like mom.
我学到的另一件事，你可能记得在沃尔玛看到过这个，人们不记得你为他们做了什么，人们记得你让他们感觉如何。我一直比我哥哥更敏感，因为他更像爸爸，而我更像妈妈。
So I try to practice sensitivity with my clients and help them know that they can pretty much be anything they want to be. So I got a job as a psychiatric social worker at UAB right out of school and I called you to tell you about it and you said, oh, I got a job
所以我尝试对我的客户实践敏感性，帮助他们知道他们几乎可以成为他们想成为的任何人。所以我毕业后在UAB找到了一份精神病学社会工作者的工作，我打电话告诉你，你说，哦，我找到了一份
at UAB as a psychiatric social worker in, what, 1962? What was it? 1965. And you said you were making
在UAB做精神病学社会工作者的工作，在，什么，1962年？是什么时候？1965年。你说你当时赚
$6,000. $6,000. A loaf of bread costs $5,000. Well, it does now. And then you said once you had your first supervision session, it was interrupted. Can you tell that story?
6000美元。6000美元。一条面包要5000美元。嗯，现在是这样。然后你说你第一次督导会议时，被中断了。能讲讲那个故事吗？
Yes, I can. It was 19... I forget the year. I was meeting with my supervisor while I was doing the field placement with retarded adults. At least that was the word that was used in those days, retarded. They're trying to retire that now. They wanted to have the...
是的，我可以。那是19……我忘了年份了。我当时正在和我的督导会面，当时我正在做智障成人的实地实习。至少那是当时使用的词，智障。他们现在正试图淘汰这个词。他们想有……
Now we say downs and other things like that. And someone came to the door, and Murray Iskowitz, my supervisor, said, they know better than to interrupt me when I'm in supervision. This better be important. And someone came to the door and said, President Kennedy has been shot. It's a ton of history. So supervision ended. But the most powerful thing that came out of that gift,
现在我们说唐氏综合症和其他类似的东西。有人敲门，Murray Iskowitz，我的督导说，他们应该知道在我督导时不要打扰我。这最好很重要。有人敲门说，肯尼迪总统被枪杀了。那是大量的历史。所以督导结束了。但那个礼物带来的最强大的事情，
since Kennedy had been like a father figure to me, was that night I had a dream, not a nightmare, that my father was in a casket in the White House and sat up to tell me goodbye. Because I never really said goodbye to my father, feeling tears in my voice now. Looking at my book, is it okay to cry? Yes, it's okay to cry. And so I had a chance to tell him goodbye. And as a matter of fact, me and my son will be going to New York and I'll be
因为肯尼迪对我来说就像一位父亲，那天晚上我做了一个梦，不是噩梦，梦见我父亲躺在白宫的棺材里，坐起来跟我道别。因为我从未真正向我父亲道别，现在声音里带着泪水。看着我的书，《哭泣可以吗？》。是的，哭泣是可以的。所以我有机会向他道别。事实上，我和我儿子将要去纽约，我大约一个月后会
taking flowers to my parents grave in about a month. Wow and you had told me a story about one time too after a lot of therapy you know you felt resolved and somebody maybe Sandy said that they they said why don't you try this gestalt chair work and why don't you talk to mom in this chair can you tell that story? Yes, I can. Sandy being Sandy Ash, one of my dearest friends in the world who I'm now practicing with also. And I had a dear
去给我父母的墓地献花。哇，你还给我讲过一个故事，在接受了大量治疗后，你知道你感到释怀了，有人，也许是Sandy，说他们建议你尝试这种格式塔椅子工作，让你在这把椅子上跟妈妈说话，能讲讲那个故事吗？是的，我可以。Sandy就是Sandy Ash，我世界上最亲爱的朋友之一，我现在也和她一起执业。我有一位亲爱的
friend, Sue Brownell, who asked me if I'd be willing to meet my deceased mother and talk with her. And I said yes. And she said, who would you like to play your mother? And I said you. And we pulled two chairs to the middle of the room. And she looked at me with all the love Sue always felt,. And before I became aware of it, Joel, my primal scream screamed, Why did you leave me?
朋友，Sue Brownell，她问我是否愿意去见我已故的母亲并与她交谈。我说愿意。她说，你想让谁扮演你的母亲？我说你。我们把两把椅子拉到房间中间。她带着Sue一直感受到的所有爱看着我。在我意识到之前，Joel，我的原始尖叫喊道：“你为什么要离开我？”
And I cried for like 15 minutes. And there was something that I needed to say. And we did work through that it wasn't her fault she had died. And that she loved me. And that I was okay.
我哭了大约15分钟。有些话我需要说。我们确实解决了那不是她的错，她去世了。她爱我。我是好的。
So I like two chair work. I like distraught work. I like psychodrama work. But that was a very powerful experience that helped me know it's okay to feel what you feel. I got angry and I cried. I think sometimes we forget what we feel because we know too much to let ourselves feel it. You know, we do all this analysis. Well said.
所以我喜欢双椅工作。我喜欢格式塔工作。我喜欢心理剧工作。但那是一次非常强大的经历，帮助我明白感受你的感受是可以的。我生气了，我哭了。我想有时我们忘记了我们的感受，因为我们知道得太多，以至于不让自己去感受它。你知道，我们做了所有的分析。说得好。
You ever thought of being a psychotherapist? I'm working on it. But, you know, we know all this stuff and we've analyzed our past and we know all these patterns and we have all this cognitive intellectual work. But we forget to just let go and feel what is beneath the surface and to get it out. And I think you were good at that, you know, using talk therapy to build a gateway to the felt experience, which is important. I mean, I would say it's the point. Thank you very much. You know, one of the things that's always struck me about you, I'm remembering like when we were in, what do they call it, Grand Rounds or Schwartz Rounds at UAB.
你有没有想过成为一名心理治疗师？我正在努力。但是，你知道，我们知道所有这些东西，我们分析了我们的过去，我们知道所有这些模式，我们有所有的认知智力工作。但我们忘记了只是放手，去感受表面之下的东西，并把它释放出来。我想你很擅长那个，利用谈话治疗建立通往感受体验的门户，这很重要。我是说，我会说这就是重点。非常感谢。你知道，有一件事一直让我对你印象深刻，我记得比如我们在，他们叫什么，UAB的大查房或Schwartz查房。
There's an auditorium of several thousand people and it's not really something that's supposed to be call and response and like your hand would go up and you would scream over the whole auditorium and the doctor would be like oh I guess we have a question you know is that you refuse to not speak when you feel something and I think that's really powerful you know like there's never a time where you don't where you feel insecure saying anything you know almost to a compulsion. And I wonder, you know, how much of that comes from being a kid that wasn't allowed to say what they felt or didn't even maybe know what you felt because there was no room for it. It's something you just refuse to be, you know, turned off now.
有一个几千人的礼堂，它并不是那种应该有呼应的东西，你的手会举起来，你会对着整个礼堂大喊，医生会说，哦，我想我们有一个问题，你知道，就是你拒绝在感到什么的时候不说话，我认为这真的很强大，你知道，就像从来没有一次你对说任何话感到不安全，你知道，几乎到了强迫的地步。我想知道，你知道，这有多少来自于作为一个不允许说出自己感受，或者甚至可能不知道自己感受的孩子，因为那里没有空间。这是你现在拒绝被关闭的东西。
I can remember when my older brother came back from West Point. I was having a problem talking on the phone, and I wasn't able to say hello, and it came out for the audience's concern. And my brother yelled at me, God damn it, can't you even say hello? I believe stuttering is trying to avoid stuttering. And I can remember asking one of the therapists we saw
我记得我哥哥从西点军校回来的时候。我在电话里说话有问题，我无法说你好，这对观众来说很担心。我哥哥对我大喊，该死的，你连你好都不会说吗？我相信口吃是在试图避免口吃。我记得问过我们见过的其中一位治疗师，
when my daughter became depressed, finding out that her boyfriend, that she was not his only girlfriend. And we entered family therapy. And I asked the therapist, how can I help my son through his phase stuttering? And he said, don't focus on it. He's not stuttering. He's just talking as well as he can and so are you so i found the courage center speech therapy because i am a stutterer and when i was asked to give a talk in this room i turned it down because quote i'm a stutterer unquote but then i found the courage several days later to call her back and say, I'd like to do the
当我女儿变得抑郁时，发现她的男朋友，她不是他唯一的女朋友。我们进入了家庭治疗。我问治疗师，我怎么能帮助我儿子度过他的口吃阶段？他说，不要关注它。他没有口吃。他只是在尽他所能说话，你也是。所以我找到了勇气进行言语治疗，因为我是一个口吃者，当被要求在这个房间里演讲时，我拒绝了，因为引用“我是一个口吃者”，但几天后我找到了勇气打电话给她说，我想做那个
talk. And I am very proud to say that I found the courage to enter speech therapy too and get to my present level of fluency. Stuttering is an interesting kind of extended metaphor. I've worked with a couple people that have that and it seems like there's this intense energy to need to say something and be heard and also this fear of saying something and being heard and getting it wrong and getting in trouble. Well said, I like that. Bumping up against each other at the same time so, you know, the speech stopped, you know, two conflicting energies. Well, I mean, I think it's interesting, you know, that you have talked kind of about the parental energy, you know, throughout your life and all the things that you bring that kind of culminate with you writing this book. Do you have anything to say about the book?
演讲。我很自豪地说，我也找到了勇气进行言语治疗，达到了我现在的流利程度。口吃是一种有趣的扩展隐喻。我和几个有这种情况的人一起工作过，似乎有一种强烈的能量需要说点什么并被听到，同时也有一种害怕说点什么并被听到，弄错了并惹上麻烦。说得好，我喜欢那个。同时撞在一起，所以，你知道，言语停止了，你知道，两种冲突的能量。好吧，我是说，我认为这很有趣，你知道，你谈到了父母的能量，你知道，贯穿你的一生，以及你带来的所有东西，最终让你写了这本书。你对这本书有什么想说的吗？
We have it in the Taproot waiting room. A lot of people have read it. And it's on Amazon, I'm proud to say. Is it okay to cry by Winschaps? And it's about a dog? You don't want to spoil the book, but do you have anything that you want to say? It's about a puppy who's afraid to cry when his mother dies because he remembers that his father once called him a crybaby.
我们在Taproot的候诊室里有它。很多人读过它。我很自豪地说，它在亚马逊上。是Winschaps写的《哭泣可以吗？》。它是关于一只狗的？你不想剧透这本书，但你有什么想说的吗？它是关于一只小狗，当他的母亲去世时，他不敢哭，因为他记得他的父亲曾经叫他爱哭鬼。
And it's the journey of the puppy, whether he can find the courage to cry at his mother's funeral because he knows that his father dog will be there at his mother's funeral. And one of the things in the book I would like to read, as a matter of fact, says, At age 11, Wynne was orphaned, and at his mother's funeral was told by a family member that his mom wouldn't want him to cry.
这是小狗的旅程，他是否能在母亲的葬礼上找到哭泣的勇气，因为他知道他的狗爸爸会出现在他母亲的葬礼上。事实上，书中的一件事我想读一下，它说，11岁时，Wynne成了孤儿，在母亲的葬礼上被家庭成员告知，他妈妈不会希望他哭。
Thus this book, and ultimately his mother's funeral was told by a family member that his mom wouldn't want him to cry. Thus this book, and ultimately his career, helping folks know that owning and sharing their feelings is an important part of loving oneself. And, emphasis on the word and, loving yourself is a huge part of overcoming psychopathology. Well, that's beautiful, Wynn. Do you have anything else that you want to plug or say? The book is available on Amazon. It is in a catered cry by one chef. If you're a taproot patient, you can also check it out in our waiting room.
因此有了这本书，最终他的职业生涯，帮助人们知道拥有和分享他们的感受是爱自己重要的一部分。而且，强调“和”这个词，爱自己是克服精神病理学的重要部分。嗯，那很美，Wynn。你还有什么想推荐或说的吗？这本书在亚马逊上有售。如果你是Taproot的病人，你也可以在我们的候诊室里借阅。
Is there anything else you'd like to say or encourage people to look up? Have the courage to enter therapy if you feel the need to find someone with whom you feel safe that you can tell anything who can help you identify the psychogenesis psychiatric origin of the issue you are facing because as a child you learned what was and wasn't okay and you learned there was no other place to live, therefore you should probably conform to what mom and dad say. Isn't it funny that Christians raise Christian children? Mormons raise Mormon children. Jews raise Jewish children.
还有什么你想说或鼓励人们去看的吗？如果你觉得有需要，请有勇气进行治疗，找到一个让你感到安全的人，你可以告诉他任何事情，他可以帮助你识别你所面临问题的精神起源，因为作为一个孩子，你学会了什么是可以的，什么是不可以的，你学会了没有其他地方可以住，因此你可能应该顺从妈妈和爸爸说的。基督徒抚养基督徒孩子不是很滑稽吗？摩门教徒抚养摩门教孩子。犹太人抚养犹太孩子。
And isn't it wonderful to know that it's okay to be you, even though I am proud to have gone to West Point, that it was okay to live my script practicing psychotherapy. So please, don't be afraid to see a therapist or a priest or a counselor
知道做你自己是可以的，这不是很棒吗？尽管我很自豪能去西点军校，但实践心理治疗来过我的剧本是可以的。所以请不要害怕去看治疗师、牧师或咨询师，
in terms of overcoming scripts you may have learned. Girls shouldn't get angry. Boys shouldn't cry. That kind of thing. I'm working with a client who was ordered to strangle a puppy to death with her mother's gun sitting in the middle of the bed,
以克服你可能学到的剧本。女孩不应该生气。男孩不应该哭。那种事情。我正在和一个客户工作，她被命令用她母亲放在床中间的枪勒死一只小狗，
which mom did every time they would sit down and talk. And therapy is helping her know that it's okay to be soft. You don't have to show power in order to be okay. So I still practice because I love practicing therapy and may always will. Well, that's beautiful. And thank you. Thank you for sitting down with us. And please check out Lynn's book. And this is the Taproot Therapy Podcast. We'll have a link to the book in the show notes and also on a blog post on GetTherapyBirmingham.com if anyone wants to pick that up.
妈妈每次坐下来谈话时都会这样做。治疗正在帮助她知道变得柔软是可以的。你不必为了表现得好而展示力量。所以我仍然执业，因为我热爱心理治疗，而且可能永远都会。嗯，那很美。谢谢你。谢谢你坐下来和我们交谈。请看看Lynn的书。这是Taproot Therapy播客。我们会在节目说明中提供这本书的链接，也会在GetTherapyBirmingham.com的博客文章中提供，如果有人想买的话。
Thank you so much for listening today. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢今天的收听。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。